this is a huge chapter where we finally
returned to the straw hats in their epic
conflict with kizaru and an elder and
see the result of the seraphim fight cp0
switching sides and more so insane and
hype so make sure to stay tuned for that
chill out parking with an ant smash that
like button if you enjoy seeing these
one piece reviews and want to keep them
coming make this the video you joined
the Knock Em Up by subscribing and
hitting that notification Bell if you
haven't already so you don't miss future
one piece reviews and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all chapter 1089 is called
the barricading incident and they really
brought a lot as we'll see soon enough
to try to finally take down Mega Punk
and now the straw hats as well we start
at fuchsia Village which is always cool
to see you know something Big's just
about to happen when Luffy's Hometown is
shown mayor whoop slap is reading about
GARP in the news but he trusts that
he'll be fine meanwhile makino's son is
laughing at Luffy's photo in the
newspaper and it's normal Luffy not gear
5. Makino says to him you've grown to
like big brother Luffy so we may have
another little pirate in the making even
if the mayor might not like the idea but
it's cool seeing Luffy inspired the
young like Shanks inspired him were
coming full circle now another sign that
the story is nearing its conclusion
relatively speaking of course I'm
personally hoping it goes for five more
years at least we then jump to mount
kalubo and to curly dadan and her
Bandits she is in tears asking what GARP
and Luffy are up to yeah Luffy is in
trouble but I think just as GARP fell
Luffy will now rise soon with a W
against an elder no less at least a
Sweet Escape suddenly an earthquake is
being felt and it's happening six days
after the Lucia Kingdom got erased there
is now a huge hole in the middle of the
sea where lolucia used to be similar to
the hole in Annie's Lobby which of
course makes us think about how that
hole came about for now we cut to people
all over the world feeling the
earthquake we get among others Momo and
wano iceberg in water 7 emu in marijuana
even my boy laboon in Twin Cape my
personal favorite edition Oda didn't
forget about our boy laboon good to see
we even get to see ivanko reacting but
the earthquake is not all the sea around
the world Rises by one meter sinking
many islands the world seems to be going
crazy right now definitely feels like a
time of great change the mayor back at
fuchsia Village is looking at the rising
water and is looking understandably
worried we then finally jumped to the
best part of the chapter in my opinion
which of course includes Luffy versus
the Marines so at Egghead Island Marine
battleships are surrounding the island
we finally see Admiral kizuru in action
as he attacks an attacking Sea Beast
weapon destroying it effortlessly with
one of his light beams pretty impressive
not gonna lie but at the same time we're
told kizaru hasn't started the attack
yet because he doesn't want to cause too
much damage to the island he tries to
get sentimaru to Just Surrender but of
course Santa mono refuses we even see a
flashback of kizuru illustrating his
power to back up punk in a young
santomaru who gets very excited this is
no surprise since we've seen beams from
the pacifistas but it's cool seeing all
these characters younger it really
flushes everyone out and cool to see
even these two had history sentimaru
even says that Uncle Punk managed to
develop a pacifista's laser by doing
research about kizuru's power he can't
believe he is the one that's coming to
kill him a good point but after kuzan
went after his mentor GARP like that
recently can't say it's surprising for
one piece kisuru is kisarudo he says he
can't cover him from the researching
void Century charges at the end he has
to obey orders and that's in alignment
with what we've gotten so far from kizu
he's now one who like kuzan challenged
and pushed back against the Marines on
orders around Egghead we see that there
are 100 Marine ships and 9 Vice Admirals
and 30 000 Marine soldiers in total and
of course most significantly Admiral
kizaru and Elder Saturn still can't wait
to see how Luffy is gonna turn this
around it's gonna be so epic and Race's
reputation further to unimaginable
levels right now especially depending on
what he does exactly just Escape which
is a possibility or maybe even take down
an admiral and or an elder in the
process I would love to see the straw
hats get matched up against Vice
Admirals and of course Luffy to take on
the Elder but we'll see what happens
doberman and doll are there among new
Vice Admirals who are sure to bring in
their own unique and exciting powers to
the mix notably vice admiral Doberman
was one of the five Vice Admirals who
led the Buster call against Annie's
Lobby so the fact that there is almost
double the number of Vice Admirals here
should tell you how seriously the
government is taking Luffy and vegapunk
it's even pointed out that this is
bigger than a buster call which is crazy
the only difference is that they do have
to be careful to keep the technology and
so they can use it for themselves for
the elders part Saint Saturn is also
eating having his meal in his room Dude
Looks like he is enjoying some wine
gotta give it to him the dude knows how
to enjoy himself before a big conflict
vice admiral Doberman comes in and gives
him a recap of the situation we see
chibi versions of all the groups as it's
being explained who's present and where
they are from the Vega punks to
seraphims to straw hats to cp0 to even
santomaru and of course we know body is
a factor as well for his part Saturn
tells doberman to sink the researcher's
ship that escaped the island earlier
because he doesn't know if one of them
knows too much clearly Saturn is not the
kind of guy to show Mercy we then see
York complaining about why they tried to
kill her along with the other vegapunks
the gorosei replied that they saw no
difference between her and the others
but after the LA Lucia incident they
have a new idea and they might keep York
to help them with producing more mother
flame weapons after we saw the
devastation one caused that's scary but
it's definitely in alignment with them
to try at this point it seems like the
Marines won't stop until the whole world
has holes in it and everything is
underwater it's revealed that York the
traitor she is is the one who also sent
the mother flame to the girl the power
plant for producing them is on Egghead
another reason they got to be careful
during this fight and it's an
interesting complication but one that I
feel like may be forgotten if the fight
gets heated enough especially if York
can survive and recreate it York made
the girl say promise not to hurt her and
the research laboratory and to make her
a world Noble they agree and we see that
Saturn and kizu are listening as well
and then comes my personal favorite part
of the chapter the twist all this time
York seemed to have been talking from
positional power but then York starts
bawling her eyes out as we see that the
straw hats have been successful they
found a way to deal with the seraphims
without much trouble it seems and Zoro
is holding his sword to York's neck
while Luffy is chilling out and eating
all is good that ends with meat as Luffy
would probably like to say usop is the
one operating the snail and everyone is
there even Bonnie and Luchi notably
Luchi doesn't look tied up and he seems
pretty chill so I'm wondering what role
he'll play in the upcoming fight
obviously he owes Luffy and seraphims
are one thing but will he go so far as
to help him against the world government
and such important figures let me know
what you think in the comments who knows
what happened during this brief time
Skip and how much these two have grown
closer during the result of this battle
of course the elders and kizuru all
sweat and are shocked when they learned
the twist that the straw hats are now
totally in control and York is begging
to be saved from Luffy like I said it's
funny they seem to be under the
impression that York was fine or that
she even dealt with the straw hats using
the seraphims but now it's clear that
the straw hats are ready for the big
fight in fact although we skipped some
stuff we didn't even see Luffy need to
go gear 5 and they had time to recover
and prepare so it really seems like the
straw hats are in a good position right
now which is a flex after having to deal
with the seraphims almost everyone's got
something to say and just gotta say this
panel is amazing I love the vibe Nami
says she gets the situation now vegapunk
says so that's how it is Bonnie says
that this really is a barricading
incident while Luffy says hilariously
mind you I don't get it but we just have
to use her meaning York as a shield to
Escape right so funny and yeah I love
that he says stuff like this that Sanji
would never say and again I gotta
emphasize it's so hyped to see the whole
crew just chilling and looking badass
especially Zorro with his confidence
Mark I love it we're also told that
there will be a break next week for all
Shonen Jump series and it's clear now
that it's finally time for them to
either Escape or win and it's going to
be one of the most epic situations in
one piece and I just love how they
invested so much into seraphims I put so
much hope into them and right now it
seems like Luffy really embarrassed the
world government by dealing with them so
easily and also the anime is almost
caught up with another one of the most
epic situations in the anime namely gear
5 and Luffy's Awakening and to honor
that I explained and ranked all 12
mythical Zone users and their powers
including Luffy's of course so see where
sun god Luffy places by clicking the
link on screen right now and I'll see
you there